it has been a long and difficult and  emotional week carl how does it feel  just to get a good win here at target  center against a very good miami team  i mean it's it's just great to be on the  court you know it's great to do what i  love and  um you know just continue to lean on  this game to uh support me and get me  through my troubles  and uh you know this game has been so  amazing to my family but for me you know  uh  in a way you know i think it saved my  life so uh  just this game puts me in a mental space  that i haven't been in in the last  week especially being home uh it put me  in a great mind  and i think the game and i think this  court and uh you know  i think this just this team these these  guys i texted them before i left to go  see my family that these guys mean  everything to me and it's because of  them that i'm able to survive this kind  of uh  tragedies in my life recently carl great  to have you back on the court and  congratulations appreciate you thank you